.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
JAR CARR.
UKRAINE CITIZENS ARE BEING GIVEN
ARMS AND SO ARE POLITICIANS.
A UKRAINIAN MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR ME.
BUT IF YOU CAN, ARE YOU
PERSONALLY TAKING UP ARMS TO
REPEL THE INVADERS?
>> YES, ON KYIV THE LARGEST
STATE IS UNDER THE INVASION OF
RUSSIA.
THEY WANT TO TAKE IT OVER IN
EVERY WAY.
THERE NO CITIZEN THAT IS NOT
THINKING ABOUT HE WILL DO ABOUT
RUSSIA TAKING OVER THE CITY.
THEY ARE TAKING UP ARMS OR
INSTRUMENT THEY CAN TO RESIST.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU SEEN RUSSIAN
FORCES WITHIN THE CITY?
>> YES.
WE HAVE SEEN RUSSIAN FORCES.
THERE HAVE BEEN SKIRMISHES WITH
VISSER GROUPS.
-- VARIOUS GROUPS.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF POW'S NOW.
WE HAVE THEM MOVING FROM THE
NORTH AND TRYING THROUGH THE
EAST.
THEY ARE TRYING TO -- SOUTH AND
WEST IS MOSTLY OPEN.
WE ARE TRYING TO KEEP IT THAT
WAY BY TAKING BACK THE WEST OF
KYIV AND THE FRONT LINES.
THAT'S THE POINT TO KEEP OUR
CITY [INAUDIBLE].
>> Tucker: DO YOU PLAN TO STAY?
>> VERY MUCH SO.
OUR PRESIDENT IS VERY NEAR WHERE
I STANDING RIGHT NOW.
THE WHOLE GOVERNMENT IS STAYING
IN KYIV.
IT'S OUR CAPITAL CITY.
WE WON'T JUST GIVE IT UP.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY.
WE DON'T WANT TO ALLOW PUTIN'S
ILLUSIONS OF GRANDEUR DESTROY
OUR DREAMS AND INDEPENDENCE OF
LIBERTY.
WE WILL FIGHT FOR THAT.
>> Tucker: HAS THERE BEEN A LOT
OF FIGHTING IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
AROUND KYIV?
>> YES.
YES, YES.
LOTS OF FIGHTING IN THE NORTH OF
KYIV.
THEY CAME IN WITH A VERY BIG
COLUMN.
THEY MOVED THROUGH CHERNOBYL AND
ENDANGERED EUROPE BY TAKING OVER
THE PLANT.
THEY HAVE MACHINERY AND INFANTRY
AND THEY GOT INTO NORTH OF KYIV.
CITIZENS RALLIED AROUND THE
ATTEMPT TO DESTROY THEM.
THEY PUSHED THEM OUT OF THE CITY
BASICALLY.
THE FIGHTING RIGHT NOW IS
HEFTIEST AROUND THE CITY.
WE ARE FACING VERSUS GROUPS WE
CAN PUSH BACK.
>> Tucker: